today's video is sponsored by surf shark
where do you see my video hey viewer
what did you see my video it's gonna
sound a little something like beta bear
dating is tough and these singles have
some horror stories to show for it who
does this in 2017 this man says a date
took a turn for the worse when the woman
he was out with started texting during a
movie
she was behaving as though this behavior
was perfectly normal brandon says he was
offended that crystal whom he met on
bumble was too busy texting with a
friend to pay attention to guardians of
the galaxy too
this is a first date first off taking a
guardians of the galaxy two's hoarding
now secondly you met her on bumble which
is a l platform okay why is it it's not
i hate that platform oh yeah yeah yeah
because it's a platform where we message
first which like i think it's good to
have a platform like that but every time
we message you first and they have to do
it it's the trash ass message
and it just hi here's why it rubs me the
wrong way because i've been on tinder
tinder and seen how they like entitled
they are to like be creative then when
they got their own platform to finally
be creative and they're the only ones
they're trash
after he spent more than 17 dollars on
her ticket about 15 minutes into the
movie the phone comes out it's text text
text read read read text text i mean it
was just it was non-stop my best friend
text me to make sure i was okay with on
my date was about a total of three texts
crystal says it was a quick chat to let
her friend know that the date was going
well
three texts is way more than letting her
know you're doing well
let's be honest
if you were into this guy or at all
interest in this date you would have
been like yeah i'm fine and then you
would have put your phone away the
reason why you kept texting because he
wasn't feeling them
because even that's disrespectful it's
just it's what it is
what do you mean
disrespectful yeah this right i'm not
crazy right no okay what's the first
date out of movies and you're just out
there on your phone sending multiple
texts i find it disrespectful but that's
just me because you have to imagine
three texts means that they're replying
going back and forth
so you got to wait a little bit time so
that phone lights out for a minute
guys if you're on a first date don't do
this i'm not even on that you know what
i'm not even on a date if i'm watching a
movie and i can see your phone over
there yes shut that [ __ ] off yeah it's
supposed to be a whole environment yes
it's supposed to be all thought you have
your whole [ __ ] thing learned it's
not it's not even the question of the
date or not
it's not even that i'm not i'm not it's
not even about that is you have the
whole [ __ ] light source lighting up
the team put your goddamn [ __ ] away all
right
damn right tell him and also the guy
looks super [ __ ] cheap for mentioning
how much he paid exactly yes 17 31 cents
like breath have some [ __ ] dignity
all right she disrespected you fine
don't do that i [ __ ] paid 17 30
better man that's that's super
childish okay
i'm all for being petty but be
creatively in a way that makes you look
half decent don't be petty be like i
paid nine dollars and 31 cents for that
data this [ __ ] was out of [ __ ] but to
be fair it's not what he said it's what
they said so maybe they were asking how
much would skip 731 and they put out i'm
gonna put it on the edit they might
you're right you know what you know what
i'll take it back [ __ ] you're right i'm
just saying but if he mentions it then
i'm going to be like ugh i really tried
that's when brandon suggested she take
her texting outside the theater
next thing i know she says i'll be right
back stands up leans in i'll be right
back
never saw her again after crystal made
her exit it was brandon sending her
texts demanding she pay back the 17
okay never mind never mind we're good
oh my god
this is petty on level never mind man
i'm sorry let me
let me read this text yo let me let me
take him i'm sorry it was me limp video
is brought to you by surfsharkvpn a vpn
is an application or an extension that
you put on top of your browser in order
to change or to mask your ip address you
know to change the location of your
computer why would you want to do that
well sometimes i want to listen to other
content from other country and they
won't let me in knock knock who's there
canada won't let you in unless you're
from the uk
switch the vpn changer and then boom
knock knock who's there
it's actually the uk now
yes come in lord come have some tea i
know you guys don't speak like that but
you know what i mean so you're able to
watch much more content and then boom
the world is open to you just like
aladdin on a carpet i can show you the
world and for the next months you have
off and before next month's free if you
use abba and preach code a search vpn
use the link below go ahead crystal your
behavior saturday was not only rude but
it cost me money i want you to
compensate me for 17 for the movie
ticket
and the four dollars for the pizza oh my
gosh
first oh
wow anybody buying four dollar pizza
deserves a big old l okay
okay that's one
two
he goes on to say will you do this or do
i have to pursue the money in small
claims court i could file online from my
laptop and i'm willing to do so your
behavior was wildly
out of line and i'm happy to pursue
putting you on the books for it
you got issues dude
dude
this went from wow she's really
disrespectful to dude have
and get the [ __ ] out
pursue someone in small claims for seven
for 21.
for 2131
divided by two
who raised you
oh my god
you know what though i sympathize with
him because life is really hard when
you're bald and short and sometimes you
get hurt so much you'd be like yo he's
entitled
right and so he came at her with that
energy my god dude and i could
understand you felt insulted i really i
wasn't i can't understand we were
rooting for you i can understand sorry
[ __ ] you get
no sympathy beyond that no go put your
energy something up she was rude but you
you this might be the most petty thing
i've ever seen if there's petty awards
i'm giving this man like top three for
sure damn bro
i text him back this is insane i am not
paying you back for the date so brandon
planned a second date for them in small
claims court
oh my god this is one date uh you know
what she's lucky she got away from you
because dude you're probably a little
bit unstable if you're this petty over
someone you met over one day imagine
being married to this [ __ ] in a
long-term relationship that's some
levels of petty that i will never no no
no no
imagine being married to this weirdo did
he lose in small claims let's find out
inside edition's megan alexander helped
settle this matter once and for all
bringing the two together for hopefully
one last time
the date just didn't work out and
i would love to give you your 17 and 31
cents if you can just leave this alone
let's count it right
[Laughter]
that's impressive
keep going he really counted that [ __ ]
i really want i really i really want to
be on your side on this
you took it too far
you seventeen
oh
you cheap who are you cheap and petty i
you know what another good kind of petty
oh you ugly
ugly you ain't got no alibi you ugly
yup
hey listen man life is already hard
enough when you're bald don't be doing
all this petty [ __ ] making it harder
doing that that's pathetic and desperate
and i start to understand ladies a
little bit more when they talk about
these dudes are [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] are
you good
i'm mourning
all right
hey
this is it uh for today
tell us what you think in the in the
comments and you know
algorithm and stuff like that
put a one in the chat if you think he
was too much
put a two if you think she was
not enough
are you good